foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
if there's a Nazi
sitting at a table
foreign people
[Music]
sitting with that Nazi at the table
you have four Nazis four of them sitting
at the table that is how this works I
have said this over and over and over
again this is not new that Nick Fuentes
is a God damn Nazi it's not new
information it's not new stuff we know
who he is we know what he is we know
what he believes it's not hard to
disseminate
that Nick Puentes is the Pied Piper of
trumped up white dudes in cells in this
country I've been saying it for a long
time that Nick Fuentes
is the absolute mouthpiece of the
Republican Party
I've been trying to tell you for months
and months and months that we need to
make every Republican
every [ __ ] one of them
Nick Fuentes his little buddy and tie
them together to buy the ankles in
shackles and throw them in to the
goddamn ocean
foreign
hypothetically all right like
not not literally
well
I've been saying it for months
months and months and months
that Nick Fuentes is the message machine
for the Republican Party
sounding the alarm
this is where it all comes from every
[ __ ] bit of this white supremacy and
white privilege
and their little white grievance that
they have going on all of its stems
from the Nick Fuentes America First
Nazis narrative
I've been calling them the America first
part Nazi party for crying out loud
Trump doesn't know who Nick Fuentes is
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
and this David Duke talk I am [ __ ]
sick and tired of the media or anyone
else I don't even care if I [ __ ] piss
you off at this point if you're tweeting
about David Duke and you're tweeting the
video about how [ __ ] Trump
didn't know who David this is ain't got
[ __ ] to do with David Duke not a [ __ ]
thing it ain't even [ __ ] close it's
not even in the same [ __ ]
Universe here's why David Duke only in
his wet dreams
would control the Republican messaging
like Nick Fuentes does
David Duke would only dream of having
Congress people sitting congressmen and
sitting congresswomen to do their
bidding
he would only [ __ ] dream of it the
clan would only dream of it only back
in the good old days was the clan in
control of politicians
this is not some [ __ ] this isn't some
coincidence this isn't just some
happenstance
that Donald Trump dined
with three of the biggest anti-semites
that we have right now on the internet
right now
this isn't uh and and of course there
are always Trump's not an anti-semite
then why in the [ __ ] why in the [ __ ]
would you take a meeting with Kanye West
knowing what the [ __ ] you know about
Kanye West right now
on Thanksgiving of all things really but
you know that's beside the point really
here when they died
and to act like [ __ ] just showed
up and knocked on the door
and you're like oh
Kanye's here let him on in who's these
who's these [ __ ] Nazis with him get
the [ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
Trump knows who Milo yiannopoulos is too
Milo was running Marjorie Taylor Green's
campaign
you dumb [ __ ]
there's no one closer to Donald Trump's
cardboard crotch than Marjorie Taylor
green
Trump
is a Nazi Nick Fuentes is a Nazi Kanye
West listen to me when I tell you this
Kanye West is a [ __ ] Nazi Milo
yiannopoulos is a [ __ ] Nazi Marjorie
Taylor green Paul gozar Matt gatz Jim
Jordan and anyone who [ __ ] sycophants
for them Kevin McCarthy you're [ __ ]
Nazis
I had a great holiday weekend it was a
great break
fantastic
turkey leftovers the whole [ __ ] bit
and over the weekend people are like oh
my God they're they're hanging out with
Nazis are you [ __ ] serious
the media is just waking up to this by
the way and they can't call them [ __ ]
Nazis the media is like oh well they're
they're anti-semites oink they're uh
white nationalist
they're the alt-right no they're [ __ ]
Nazis got it
it's enough of this stupid [ __ ]
it's enough of the nonsense
two of the [ __ ] sitting at the
table with the Nazi who are Nazis
are pretending to run for president in
2024.
they're going to be collecting [ __ ]
people's money they're going to be
grifting people's money to run for
president in 2024.
and support
apparently Milo is Kanye's
is his [ __ ] campaign manager Milo
yiannopoulos is a [ __ ] pedophile
he's openly talked about how he likes to
have sex with underage boys
and they're cheering this the people who
are like oh
Joe Biden was called over to a window so
he could have a selfie I'm going to show
you this video these [ __ ] weirdos
these creeps can't even [ __ ] can't even
[ __ ] garnish enough [ __ ] muster
enough courage to tell the truth
they they [ __ ] project their
pedophilia their their [ __ ] weirdness
and they're [ __ ] closeted trumped up
white ideas all over everyone else
thank you
and I'm I'm sick of [ __ ] I'm not get
you know me I'm not gonna give a [ __ ]
I'm gonna say it
I don't give a [ __ ]
Nick Fuentes is and has been for a long
time a [ __ ] Nazi
Marjorie Taylor green went and spoke at
the America First Nazi party the rally
that they had
Nestor CPAC the [ __ ] walked over
to CPAC and talked about how he's a Nazi
praising Hitler praising Putin and they
keep doing this [ __ ] too calling him a
holocaust denier
wink the media's like well he's a
holocaust denier just say it say it
they're [ __ ] Nazis
it's not hard it really is an easy word
to say
well they're not actually part of the
Nazi they're Nazis
it's not difficult to [ __ ] figure
this out
we can see it right out in the open
everyone's standing around wondering
Ben Shapiro
oh my God
this is great too Ben Shapiro and Kanye
West get into it over the weekend on
Twitter
right
for all you who don't know Ben Shapiro
is a Jewish anti-semite
that's right Ben Shapiro is a Nazi
sympathizer which makes him a [ __ ]
Nazi and he he he's got the daily wire
which continues continues to house the
world's weirdest [ __ ] propaganda Matt
Walsh who continues to project
his every thought and fantasy into his
content Jesus Christ you [ __ ] weirdos
but Ben Shapiro and Kanye West get into
this argument on Twitter oh and you know
it's really funny because
the platform that Kanye has
stolen by Candace Owens
you remember the fashion show
where it all started
we're all this [ __ ] nonsense the last
few months has started and here we are
talking about how Kanye and his little
Nazi friends are dining with the King
Nazi Trump himself
but Kanye West wore the White lives
matter
sweater with Candace Owens at some
[ __ ] fashion thing as if anyone
anyone in the Trump universe and the
Trump cult would have any [ __ ] idea
what the [ __ ] this fashion thing was
that they were wearing these sweaters at
trust me I don't even [ __ ] know what
the [ __ ] it is no clue couldn't give a
[ __ ] less really about some fashion show
could not give a [ __ ] less about some
fashion show in France or some [ __ ]
couldn't give a [ __ ] less
but that's where it all started
that's where it all started
and then it went on and on and on as he
continued with his anti-semitic [ __ ]
talk
about the Jewish media and the Jewish
Banks and on and on and on and on the
lies go on and on and on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] spreads
and Kanye's just a megaphone here
he's not he's not the idea guy trust me
not an idea rolling around in that guy's
head that hasn't been put there
but it doesn't matter
it doesn't
matter
and we're standing around we're standing
around wondering why these [ __ ]
can't call Trump out by name listen if
you can't if you can't get on social
media or you can't go on television and
say Trump I condemn Donald Trump
for for [ __ ] dining with Nazis
and I will not support him because he
did this you are a [ __ ] Nazi
pretty simple it's not complicated it
really isn't it should be pretty [ __ ]
simple
Nick Fuentes is never a hid who he is or
what he stands for or what his ideas are
why do you think he's the Pied Piper of
the trumped up inside white dudes
he appeals to their their their their
their
every single fear he appeals to it their
fear that they may they may find a woman
at a bar and take the woman home and oh
my God his chest may have a penis
they're terrified terrified
that they may have to treat a woman like
a woman for her to like him
instead of acting like some [ __ ]
idiot
terrified terrified
that even with all their white privilege
they still will amount to nothing
that's who these [ __ ] that's who
these followers these supporters are
Patriot front the alt-right
Vanguard whatever the [ __ ] you want to
Brand them as America First Nazi party
whatever it is they're [ __ ] Nazis
they have been the entire time
this isn't news
this isn't something something that has
just been discovered
I've been yelling and screaming about it
for months and then you know the the
weird part here
is I've been saying hey ever Republican
needs to be
treated the same as we treat Nick
Fuentes because Nick Fuentes is the
messaging machine for the America First
the Maga arm of the [ __ ] Republican
Party
where do you think it all comes from
every [ __ ] bit of it why do you think
they're cheering Kanye they're cheering
Kanye not because he's Kanye not because
he's black not because he's an
anti-semite it's because someone with a
megaphone
is is
absolutely amplifying their message just
like Elon Musk this morning he's he's
[ __ ] tweeting Pepe pepit and frog
memes he's a [ __ ] Nazi that's right
I'm on I'm on Twitter right now live on
Twitter Elon Musk Elon you are a [ __ ]
Nazi
it's pretty [ __ ] simple
we don't have to [ __ ] we don't have
to be
we do not
we do not
have to be light and be polite
to the Nazis and consider their feelings
[ __ ] you
if you're with them you're with them and
you're a Nazi
it's just how it [ __ ] works
there it's not an opinion either by the
way these are not opinions
these opinions that they they want to
[ __ ] put put people in gas Chambers
they want to deny what happened
in Nazi Germany
they want to extinguish
marginalized communities in this country
I I'm not saying this [ __ ] Matt Walsh is
saying it Nick Fuentes is saying it
Marjorie Taylor green is saying it
so I I can't I can't do I cannot [ __ ]
control what they say I can only point
it out
and yeah you should be [ __ ] pissed
you should be pissed
that the media even this morning the
media is still talking about David Duke
as if this is some kind of [ __ ] 1980s
1990s Ku Klux Klan type [ __ ] this is not
the same this is not the same listen
half the Country Wasn't hopped up on
[ __ ] Q Anon
when David Duke was running around
Again David Duke only in his wet dream
could fathom having the control over a
certain amount of population like these
[ __ ] have a cult type control
over
Trump knew exactly what he was doing
exactly
what he was doing when he met with Kanye
West Milo yiannopoulos and Nick Fuentes
dining with them
foreign
now he's a [ __ ] idiot
he's a dumb [ __ ]
and he didn't realize the Fallout
from the rest of the country
he was only looking at one thing that he
always looks at the most
how much will the Tail Wag this dog
and that's what he sees in Kanye West
Milo yiannopoulos and Nick Fuentes
they're influential
for God's sake I mean people listen to
him
that's why you cannot like glove these
[ __ ]
you gotta stop with the oh he's a
holocaust denier no
well he is a white Nash he's a white
supremacist he's a racist he's a bigot
he's a Nazi it's simple it's easy to say
I'm saying it right now and I've said it
a thousand times today Nazis Nazis Nazis
it's not difficult media it's not
difficult to type it in it's not
difficult to say it out loud
how do you think
that the world escalated
in the 1930s and the 1940s in Europe how
do you think it escalated
how do you think these crazy [ __ ]
ideas took hold
it's because no one would call them for
what they are
ah well you know he's kind of eccentric
that Hitler he's kind of eccentric
he's got some wild ideas
you know maybe maybe some of the things
he says but you know he's people really
aren't taking him seriously
I have a lot of faith in our democracy
as you know
I think the fabric of our country is
very strong as a matter of fact
I'm not one to think that democracy is
on the ropes I actually think democracy
is throwing punches
like a [ __ ]
it's the it's it's the beat reporters
it's the ones talking into the
microphone on the sidelines
you know calling the match
they're the ones
who aren't seeing what we're seeing
I'll tell you something there's lines in
Georgia all weekend
lines of people voting
they're hell-bent
on saving this democracy
even if it just means one seat in the
senate in Georgia
and nothing gives me more confidence now
than ever seeing the amount
of gen Z being engaged in their country
and their democracy
educating themselves
making sure the other Generations hear
their voice
for some reason and I'm not sure exactly
where we come to this point and maybe
just maybe
it was the inevitability of trump and
trumpism with white privilege and white
grievance in this country
maybe just maybe
that is what has made democracy sexy
again with these gen's ears
think about the Antiquated ideas
that were that word that that were
absolutely puked up at the table with
these [ __ ] Nazis down at Mar-A-Lago
think about the Antiquated ideas
the old tropes that were probably slung
around
the table
as they eat their Big Macs or whatever
the [ __ ] they were eating
there's an entire generation
of Americans
diverse
and ready to fight for their democracy
and the most beautiful part about it
is that they're not in it for one issue
other
than democracy itself
they fully understand
and it is clear that they understand
that until we get past the point
where these Nazis have any kind of of
breadth of power anywhere in our country
the fight must be for our democracy
they understand this they are
implementing it
and they are going to be successful
wildly successful
I can't tell you how more excited I am
to see what will become of this
generation that is Gen Z
I would imagine there's going to be some
of the greatest leaders in our that our
country has seen in Generations
so have no fear
about
the nincompoop Nazis who met down at
Mar-A-Lago decided to break bread about
their presidential campaign runs in
2024. we will beat them
we have beat them before we will beat
them again
it is up to us though
we must point this out we must call them
out
and we anyone anyone who will not stand
and say [ __ ] Trump and [ __ ] those Nazis
you're one of them that's right
if you are not if you are not standing
up and saying and rebuking them
full stop a hundred percent
the whole way not just oh well there's
this guy who met with uh this other guy
who's a Holocaust in Iron that's a bad
thing say the names
say the names
[ __ ] and if they don't they're
with them
if we can't get the leaders of the
Republican Party who are sitting
in office
currently
to rebuke this [ __ ]
they're the same [ __ ] they
would take the same meeting
guaranteed
Ron DeSantis Brian Kemp
Kerry Lake Marjorie Taylor green Kevin
McCarthy Mitch McConnell they would take
the same meeting
if they cannot stand
against what happened over the weekend
same [ __ ]
same [ __ ]
I am so happy that we are back on the
air I am so happy that you are with us
the best audience in the entire world
here at the Tony Michaels podcast we had
a Thanksgiving break it was great to
have a break
um I do have some news though Gabe
Sanchez
um did I was sick last week and was
having voice trouble Gabe Sanchez is
having some voice trouble today so he
will be joining us tomorrow he did the
great art today though
um so maybe I can get him to come in the
chat or something I don't know
get out there on Twitter and see if
he'll come in the chat and chat with you
guys while we're uh why we're talking
because we got a lot of stuff to round
up I got a lot of uh on the [ __ ] list as
long as Twitter is still operational
here we're gonna look through some video
oh my God let me tell you something
speaking of Nazis and can the Cheeto
dusk Confederacy Carrie lake has a huge
following out in Arizona that's
trying to make sure she's installed as
the governor that's hilarious and
pathetic we're going to go over that
oh my God I also want to show some video
of Herschel Walker because this is a
super important race we are getting down
to the wire on uh this runoff in Georgia
everyone needs to be paying attention to
this runoff and leaning into it as much
as possible so I want to show you some
video there
and then also we're going to read some
of uh Grandpa poopypants's
post on fraud social I don't we don't do
that a lot because he's been posting a
lot but we're going to today and the
reason why is because he is [ __ ]
terrified of Jack Smith I mean he is oh
my God it's getting
I don't know I don't know how much stock
they got and Depends down there at
Mar-A-Lago
but Jack Smith
uh better we better buy stock and
depends I don't know what diaper brand
uh Trump uses do you guys know I don't I
have no idea I don't know but uh maybe
Jack Smith will get to the bottom of it
everybody you are the best audience in
the entire world we run off your support
here at the Tony Michaels podcast if you
want to give us a tip go to Tony
michaels.live go to Tony michaels.live
you can give a one-time tip or set it up
monthly or if you want something
we've got these great sweaters and they
make great Christmas gifts great
Christmas gifts
for all your your democracy loving
family you know what it wouldn't make a
bad gift for a trump supporter too I bet
they would wear this son of a [ __ ] I
bet they would wear it it's warm it's
warm we got all kinds of colors go to
store.thedonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com thank you for
all your support everyone these uh these
Liberty sweaters have been flying off
the shelves there's hoodies zip up
sweaters zip up jackets
and we also got t-shirts and coffee mugs
so head over to
store.ttonymichaels.com at store not
need Tony michaels.com you can use the
promo code podcast and get 10 off that's
right use the promo code podcast get 10
off your entire order get it for the
holidays buy your family members have a
ton of that stuff underneath the
Christmas tree everyone stick around we
will be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
speaking of Nazis they were really upset
this weekend they were they were really
upset that the president United States
is walking down the street drinking his
milkshake I don't know what it was
milkshakes he's just walking down the
street
people see him through the window like
hey Mr President Mr President we want a
selfie and he hears them through the
window and he walks I'm going to show
you the video
and he walks over to the window and they
got their selfie these kids what a great
Moment by the way
that that the president United States
could go over and give him a selfie
through the window
and of course the selfiest Post online
because you know you get a selfie with
the president United States you might be
excited about it you might want to post
it on your social media right
Hell Boy well the right wing absolutely
you know they're all hopped up on Q Anon
yeah cubanon's hell of a drug
it's a hell of a drug can you imagine
running around just believing whatever
the [ __ ] you want to believe
that that actually doesn't sound too bad
sometimes
it doesn't sound too bad I mean there's
certain conspiracy theories
that are worth considering just for the
simple fact that you would like to
believe them
it's true
I'm just saying
sometimes
you know conspiracy theories can be a
hell of a drug
and Q Anon is one hell of a conspiracy
theory so when you're all hopped up on
these conspiracy theories and you get
[ __ ]
Elon Musk running Twitter Jesus Christ
this guy did you see the [ __ ] picture
that he posted of his goddamn nightstand
or whatever
number one who puts that picture on
there no one puts that [ __ ] picture
on their nightstand man come on me he's
got like 30 kids he ain't got one
picture of his kid on the [ __ ]
nightstand the next thing is the [ __ ]
12 [ __ ] Diet Coke caffeine free cans
come on no one drinks that garbage I'm
not talking about Diet Coke I'm talking
about the caffeine-free [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] it's like decaf coffee get the [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense what's
the point of drinking this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] the point
I mean I mean why why would you want to
smoke cigarettes without all the
barbiturates in it you know the nicotine
the rat poison come on
drinking diet Coke without the caffeine
yeah come on [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's the
whole point like literally you're doing
the diet thing
so you see you don't so you don't feel
fat because it well let's be honest the
[ __ ] Diet Coke doesn't make you less
fat but then then you go to the extent
of drinking a diet coke which isn't real
coke
and taking the caffeine out this is
ridiculous
and then everyone was upset about the
about the gun I think that's really what
the picture was about right and he was
trying to own the lips as if liberals
don't have guns on their nightstand
people really are [ __ ] stupid that
you don't think liberals own guns and
liberals know how to use guns this is
really dumb stupid [ __ ]
and that that liberals would be
triggered by the gun
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
it was the [ __ ] rings on the
nightstand that got it for me right
here he is supposed billionaire pays 44
billion dollars for Twitter and can't
afford for someone to come in and clean
the [ __ ] the soda rings off his
nightstand
God damn
and shit's rough over there
at the musk household and I want to show
you this video
and um a President Biden okay here's
here's Jack prostates little little post
here he says oh OMG
okay
of this picture of these kids happy that
the president is taking a selfie with
them through the window right
now of course they're trying to make
this look like a creepy picture the
problem is the problem is is that these
they took a video of what happened
right there's there's like video of it
this is a problem
and the reason why it's a problem is
because the only reason why the
president United States went over to
this window in the first place
is because there were people inside who
noticed the president of the United
States was walking down the street and
was yelling at him through the window
and he heard them
it's kind of a weird thing when you know
a human interaction
someone calls your name you turn you
notice they're calling you over you walk
over there it's kind of a weird thing in
you know this human interaction but
maybe these Nazis just don't
um get that at this point but here is
the [ __ ] video here it is okay here's
jail
oh my God
[Music]
okay oh my God they seem so scared of
him
oh
I just I can't I you guys know I don't
even talk about Joe Biden a lot on this
[ __ ] program and the reason why is
because Joe Biden gets up in the morning
he puts his [ __ ] shoes on and he does
his [ __ ] job
almost better than any president in
modern history there's not a lot for me
to [ __ ] talk about to be quite honest
with you I mean other than to brag about
him and I feel like that gets culty
right I don't want this to be in the
show about [ __ ] the president United
States how great he's doing and you know
I'm not a [ __ ] boot licker like the
rest of these [ __ ] trumped up pieces
of [ __ ] I'm just not gonna lick Joe
Biden's boots I'm not gonna do it [ __ ]
him and really honestly he's doing a
great job without me without anyone
licking his [ __ ] boots
because he's working for the American
people not not for the attention
not so he can have big rallies and
people can show up and cheer him on
because he's a [ __ ] loser that's not
that's not who he is
but I just find it funny that any any
moment they can find any moment they can
find
to try to to try to turn him into some
kind of creep there's video evidence
that it's the exact opposite the only
reason why the president was over near
that window is because people were
excited that he was walking down the
street
they were excited to see Joe Biden
they think he's a great president they
think he's a good person a decent human
being
and not only not only did the right wing
decide oh well we're going to try to
turn this into a moment they basically
pointed out to the entire world that
people love Joe Biden they just pointed
it out
I mean why they couldn't go and make
sure and you know maybe before we post
this picture that we think looks creepy
maybe we should go do a little bit of
backstory and find out you know watch
the video before the picture on the
Instagram maybe we should find out if
this
situation is a situation that's gonna
not play into our narrative but they
don't give a [ __ ]
the reason why I don't give a [ __ ]
is because they have people like Miley
Annapolis Kanye West
Nick Fuentes Marjorie Taylor green Jack
prostate Charlie Kirk Matt Walsh Ben
Shapiro to push lies
into the minds of
Americans who are all hopped up on Q
Anon
because that's what this is
this this theory that somehow he was
weirdly creepily looking through the
window at these children it's all cute
and unconspiracy Theory
it's not true there's no shred of
evidence in it other than he was looking
through the window because they called
him over to look to literally that's
what happened the children are like hey
come here we want you over here to take
a selfie because that's what [ __ ]
kids do and we want to selfie with the
president and there's a window and you
can look through it and it
but again
we have to point this [ __ ] out and the
reason why is because they're they're
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] and they're [ __ ]
Liars
and they'll do anything anything to push
their narrative
absolutely anything this is a weird
[ __ ] video that Patriot takes posted
I think this is um what's that [ __ ]
weirdo from oan
certain name you know what I'm talking
about
um if if Sanchez was here he'd know her
name uh she's the she's the one that
says weird [ __ ] she's a host of a show
Believe It or Not
she's some kind of [ __ ]
trumped up Nazi influencer on on
Instagram she posts videos where she
goes around San Diego yelling and
screaming at at places that have the
the pride flag yeah Margie says the
blonde yeah that one the blonde I don't
know her [ __ ] name I I I I you know a
lot of this [ __ ] I have to get rid of in
my brain I gotta remember a lot of [ __ ]
I can't remember every single ah there
we go uh the mighty librarian has it
Steinberg Allison that's it Allison I
believe that's who this is I think
that's who this is
in this video
now there I I think it's at a
Thanksgiving thing and here uh you see
this guy sitting here it might be staged
um just for the sake of burning a Nike
shirt but you see the guy here wearing
this t-shirt and you see uh off camera
here I think this is Allison I believe
and Jared says Nazi Barbie yeah you know
not too far off
um but here is uh here is is that her
see there's the beginning of the video
is that her I don't know I can't really
tell I think it's her
I think it's her
I don't know
so here is um
here's the video it's [ __ ] weird now
again you gotta remember these are the
people who are always like oh the left's
trying to cancel everything they want to
cancel everything they don't want anyone
to to to have their ideas they're trying
to force people to have their ideas and
demons and blah blah and the Jewish
media and all kinds of weird ass [ __ ]
all kinds of weird [ __ ] Q Anon
Nazi type [ __ ]
but listen to her in this video what she
says to her friend who has literally
she's triggered by his T-shirt watch
this my friend is really upset right now
because
everyone's coming for him as a result of
his very poor shirt choice but I want
you all to rest assured that we've had a
discussion and he knows better he's
gonna burn that [ __ ]
so there you go see
cancer culture at its best
foreign
right there can't even [ __ ] handle
can't even handle being in the same room
as a Nike shirt what a [ __ ] snowflake
and by the way
by the way
this Nike shirt
this Nike shirt
is probably from like 1997. I haven't
seen a Nike shirt like this in a long
time
the sleeves have been cut off the shirt
for years probably
I I to some degree I think this is
staged right
but here she is trying to cancel
her friend's t-shirt because she is so
offended and so upset
she cannot she will melt this snowflake
will melt as she's in a room with this
t-shirt any longer which I'm not sure
oh and now here and uh Andrew from
Facebook says what the [ __ ] is the
problem with Nike uh who knows it's the
same old [ __ ] Andrew
like they get something in their crawl
and they they get all [ __ ] butt hurt
about something all offended because
Nike supports lgbtq or something
and really honestly it's not like Nike
is some sort of Pride organization they
just you know Corporate America
understands
um capitalism and they understand
that the majority of Americans aren't
going to patronize their [ __ ]
business and buy their [ __ ] products
if they're bigots
right so what happens a lot of times at
these corporations is they have to
appear to not only not be bigots but to
appear to support
marginalized communities so that they
can't be accused of not right I mean
deep down in my soul do I believe every
[ __ ] company
that has something on their website or
changes their their Avatar during pride
month
are shows support during Black History
Month do I believe that they truly in
their heart of hearts deep down inside
adhered to every single one of those
principles I you know I don't know it's
not for me to judge it's for you that's
the great part about capitalism is it's
democracy right your your dollars are
your votes
speaking of that they already bought
this shirt by the way see the shirt
she's pointing at here she's pointing at
his shirt as he's taking a bite of
whatever the hell [ __ ] she made probably
they already bought the Nike shirt like
Nike's already got the money right like
this is Nike's got the money and this
kid's cut the sleeves off the shirts
even
so listen to what she says though that
she's gonna force him to do right
because she this is this is a left-wing
thing that the left forces people to do
things and to think certain ways
watch this
after today so actually why don't you
just do it now there's a lighter [ __ ] to
it boy
burn it now here we go
again this is the same stupid [ __ ] like
when uh Colin Kaepernick was kneeling
kneeling during the national anthem had
nothing to do with the anthem and just
he was just peacefully silently
protesting
and black men were being killed by
police officers all over the country
needlessly
and he was protesting and he was making
a statement quietly by the way
he wouldn't say an anti-semitic [ __ ]
into a microphone for sure
he was quietly protesting where he could
and he was respectfully protesting by
kneeling and they were like NFL I'm
burning my jersey
because he's
insulting the military or some [ __ ]
which it had nothing to do with the
military actually him taking a knee
came from a veteran that was in the NFL
that told him hey stop sitting on the
bench that's disrespectful if you want
to respect the flag and the anthem
you should kneel if you want to protest
so that's what he did
and they lost their minds
they wanted a cancer Colin Kaepernick
which they did they canceled Colin
Kaepernick
they canceled kneeling during the anthem
canceled it your freedom of speech yeah
you [ __ ] Freedom Bros huh
you can't [ __ ] you can't freely
Express
your descent for police officers all
around the country murdering black men
needlessly
you can't you don't have the freedom to
protest that anymore because they
believe in Freedom no they don't
let's let's watch him burn the Nike
shirt [ __ ] off Nike
yeah [ __ ] you Nike how do you really
feel [ __ ] you Nike
my friend is really so there it is
and the only reason why I bring this up
the only reason why I show this video is
because of how ridiculous they are right
how triggered they truly are
now this could be [ __ ] staged right
which honestly it makes it even worse
it makes it way worse if this is staged
way worse that means they planned on
acting like snowflakes they planned on
canceling this kid's Nike shirt
oh Jesus
whoosh well let's check in with um some
more of the Republican party and let's
see if they'll actually say Trump's name
in the word Nazi
and let's see if the media will use the
word Nazi let's see what the uh current
governor the outgoing governor of
Arkansas has to say let's listen you
personally prosecuted white supremacist
groups what's your reaction to seeing a
former U.S president associate with
someone like that
well I hope someday we won't have to be
responding to what uh former president
Trump has said or done in this instance
it's important to respond and as you
mentioned the last time I met with a
white supremacist it was in an armed
standoff I had a bulletproof vest on we
arrested them prosecuted him sent them
to prison and so no I don't think it's a
good idea for a leader that's setting an
example for the country or the party to
meet with a vowed racist or anti-semite
and so it's very troubling and it
shouldn't happen and we need to avoid
those kinds of empowering the extremes
and when you meet with people you
empower and that's what you have to
avoid you want to diminish their
strength not Empower them stay away from
it
well there you have it at least one
person is willing to say the word Trump
and anti-semite in the same sentence he
didn't go as far as I would go and call
Nick Fuentes and Milo yiannopoulos and
Kanye West Nazis but he he almost got
there now
here's the thing
and here's why weeks ago people were
like God damn Tony wants Trump to run
for president this is exactly why
this is exactly why I knew I knew that
[ __ ] would not do anything but
point out the the vile [ __ ] movement
on the right
he's not going to be president he's
probably not even going to be the
nominee unfortunately no I I seriously I
want him to be the nominee I want them
to have to [ __ ] choose
they should have to choose I hope he
gets all the way you know I I hope I
hope they don't imprison him
and deal with convention or at least or
after the convention
I'm serious now I want him to try to go
on the convention floor the Republican
National Committee
and try to get the nomination again
it will tear them the [ __ ] apart
they will be fractured beyond belief
they will be in pieces
do you have any idea how easy it would
be for any candidate on the Democratic
side to beat whoever comes out of that
convention it's going to be phenomenal
especially as the demographics are
changing it's engaged
as gen Z is
don't doubt
don't doubt our ability to politicize
this
it's gonna work
but Asha Hudson's in here knows what
side he wants to be on at the convention
that's really what is going on here the
Larry Hogans the Kemps the Asha Hudson's
what they're doing that Liz Cheney's the
Adam kinzinger's
they're aligning themselves
to take the vote on the floor away from
trumpism at the next convention they
know that's the challenge here
and it doesn't matter if it's Trump
himself or you know a Nazi placeholder
for Trump
their parties at a crossroad
and what we have to do is politicize
every moment of this
and drive those wedges deep down inside
their party
we can't get rid of the Nazis right like
we can't get rid of Nazis in their party
what are we supposed to do about it the
only thing we can do is go vote against
them that's it to make sure they don't
have power we can't keep the Nazis out
of their party we can't do that
I mean we can we can sure shame them and
mock the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of them
maybe it'll maybe it'll get there
but they're the ones who have to get rid
of it they're the ones who have to clean
house we're not responsible
for the [ __ ] that goes on in their
party that's not our responsibility
it's on them
now we can hold them accountable
by pointing it out showing it to
everyone on the planet okay let's go to
another video here of a Nazi uh and a
lot of people are spreading this around
over the weekend I don't know when this
was it seems like it's been
um
before the weekend though
this this video popped up in Seattle
right
um I'm not sure when it was it's it's
not sure I get to conflicting dates but
it doesn't change what happened it was
in Seattle Washington in an airport
and some some [ __ ] Nick Fuentes type
was arrested in the airport
the reason why is because he's throwing
up the Heil Hitler's salute saying hail
Hitler and he wants a race war
now
let me tell you something
this guy definitely knows you Nick
Fuentes is 100 full stop this guy
throwing up the Nazi salute here
definitely knows who Nick Fuentes is
listen to this ridiculous [ __ ] inside
this airport and these people's reaction
is priceless but watch
first floor
foreign
people are laughing like what in the
[ __ ] is this guy serious like At first
you're like it just can't be real I
think this is just some person hanging
like a fool nope nope not not that way
this guy's way off his rocker his social
media and [ __ ] is just out off the chain
off the chain this guy is
the thing is here
is that luck folks
a lot of people were upset about this
[ __ ] video Yeah triggered upset
this is who they are
this is who who they are trying to get
to vote for them
right this is who they are attracting to
their party like fake Gabe in the
comments all the time this is him
this is him he likes this guy
this is his guy
all his political beliefs all his
[ __ ] he would type in this guy who's
saying hail Hitler
in the airport like a crazy person like
he hadn't had his meds lately this
[ __ ] here
would be typing in the same exact [ __ ]
into the chat okay that's very Gabe same
[ __ ] he would be typing in the same
nonsense right
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] same
it's a little better here let's continue
to watch here's Anna 30 seconds left
[Music]
okay so he's pointing at the woman and
he's he's getting all testy with the
employees the one thing you saw there is
that the woman who's yelling at now
directed another person behind the
counter they're like go shut that
[ __ ] gate door we can't let this guy
get out into the [ __ ] plane this
guy's lost his [ __ ] [ __ ]
scary it's not it's not fully there
he's way off the rails so they closed
the gate door so they can't get into the
you know no one can get into the plane
at this point so now he's pissing
everybody off right
because everyone's looking at the door
closing going ah [ __ ] I thought I was
gonna get on a plane
and here this Nazi is y'all are
screaming about Hitler and race war and
now he's now he's taking out his white
grievance on this woman because he's
acting a fool he's gonna get arrested he
does get arrested by the way
and the airport they hold them down and
arrested snowflake gas and I don't know
I don't know what's this event to happen
right does it [ __ ] matter no it does
not matter why he decided to go on all
all Nazi Karen
uh in the airport
it doesn't matter
here's the thing the reason why this
video is important and the reason why we
must show this is to show who they are
okay
it is important to show who they are
these are fragile trumped up white dudes
I keep saying it over and over and over
and over again
it's an army of incels the shark army
that's why Trump had Nick Fuentes to
dinner
is because Nick Fuentes is the [ __ ]
Avenue it's the ticket to [ __ ]
like this going and voting for Trump
it's not difficult to understand
this stuff is easy
Trump knows he's voting for him Trump
knows who supports him he knows that
he's not he's he's
he is not that dumb he is not
let's continue
um with the lieutenant here in the shirt
Army
oh I I love the girl's reaction down
here young lady's reaction I don't know
how she maybe she's older than I think
you know watch her she's like are you
[ __ ] kidding me is this guy's serious
she's pissed off because they closed the
gatewatch
[Music]
oh man I wish I had the I don't know I
could probably find the video where he
got arrested
um that's satisfying but this is again
this is yeah we gotta point this [ __ ]
out you can't go without saying this
[ __ ] right you can't go without showing
this [ __ ] this is the same weird ass
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] that you saw from
the uh
the the shooter at Club Q's dad
it's same [ __ ] same [ __ ] oh by
the way hey fake game I know I don't
know if your buddies with the Q
Shooter's dad but you man you guys
should really hook up
I'm serious wow you guys like you guys
really get along I'm sure in the DMs
you're saying
have you seen these videos of the dad
from the the Club Q shooter
did we show this on the on the [ __ ]
show I don't know we we've been gone for
several days so it's hard for me to
remember
and I I had a few alcoholic beverages
over the weekend you know
I partaked
I was partaking in holiday celebrations
God damn it
I may have
um ground view memories and MJ says show
it uh MJ did I did I show this last week
MJ's always on top of things I don't
know if I showed the uh the dad video
but we're not going to hide from it
We're Not Gonna hide from it oh I have
some I got some remind me I've got some
video here of the um
the Insurrection that's happening out in
Arizona where they're trying to
overthrow the government and they're
going to install Kerry Lake and there's
tens of people who have shown up to do
this and don't let me forget that one
whoo that's a great one here we go here
here it is
here's the video of the dad
here's the video of the dead now if this
guy doesn't remind you of the last guy
in the airport I don't know what will
again this is the
I don't know what I I again he's on some
something
he's on he's either on something or he's
off his mids one or the other in this
video
but this is the dad
of the Club Q shooter who got his
[ __ ] teeth kicked in
by a trans woman a veteran
and someone else there in the in the
club got his [ __ ] teeth kicked and
really honestly
um not enough if you want to know the
honest truth I want I saw pictures of
the Club Q shooter have you seen this or
he's got his face all [ __ ] up not
enough not enough let's listen to his
[ __ ] his meched out Dad here for the
shooting involved in the multiple people
and then I thought and they're on one
fine there's a gate Barn yeah right and
everybody
ow [ __ ] so here's the news that his son
was in a gay bar right
he hears the news that his son is in the
gay bar
he he murdered five people
murdered five people injured like
another 21.
within a minute or two
I'm sure
and the thing this guy is worried about
his dad
oh thank God he's not gay
which honestly I don't give a [ __ ] if he
is or not like the kid I don't know that
it seems like the lawyers are trying to
do this non-binary thing as a strategy
to avoid hate crimes or some [ __ ] and
maybe this kid is repressing feelings
and his dad this piece of [ __ ] here
um absolutely [ __ ] drove him
to go kill people because he you know
it's hard to tell there's a lot of
[ __ ] problems with this family I bet
you know most of them are psychological
I mean some of the [ __ ] that this guy
continues to say here on this interview
is [ __ ] vile and gross
and really
it makes me want to watch
uh some trans women in high heels you
know leave imprints on his face to be
quite honest because it feels like to me
that the dad is almost as culpable in
the deaths of the five people
but I don't give a [ __ ] at the club Q
Shooters gay or not I don't give a [ __ ]
who cares
[ __ ] brought in a weapon of war
and murdered five people and injured 21
more but wasn't for that veteran the
performer and another bystander he'd
have killed more
he'd killed more
because he is a [ __ ] little weak
little cuck
and his dad here is a weak little cuck
and I'm sure the reason why his dad
hates the gays and doesn't want his son
to be gay is because of reasons that you
know he's repressing and been repressing
for a long time let's continue with the
meth out little
diet dry beer well you guys have had
conversations about that you you were oh
yeah yeah Republican
and we don't do gay okay yeah
it really feels like he's you know
holding in something here doesn't it to
you like when someone is this [ __ ] I
mean just I'm a conservative I'm of cons
Mormon and and we don't do we don't do
gay
whoosh you don't do gay I don't know if
anyone does gay I don't know if that's
how it works and I don't know
let's continue okay yeah I can't get
answers from the attorneys really but
they're saying that somebody's really
this involving a gay bars or something I
don't know
um I don't know what the heck you do if
you have a gay bar um
I don't know well he's accused of going
on a mass shooting at a gay bar and
killing so there it is I guess that's
when he found out his son is a [ __ ]
Mass killer let's let's watch his
response
okay well
well I saw [ __ ] I've excused of doing
that I I'm gay well he's accused of
killing five people he's a murderer he's
a mass murderer but at least he's not
gay
listen
if you're still not trying to figure out
why the [ __ ] Nick Flint is Milo
Annapolis and Kanye West met
with Donald Trump
it it it lives and embodies and breathes
inside this meth-out skin suit
right here
it's hatred it's [ __ ] hatred
oh I can say that my body's okay
pure
cold-blooded hatred and there's another
video now let me find it here
it's really even worse almost
um
this is the one that I believe makes
this [ __ ] culpable and this
entire Act of murdering people
just for dressing up and singing oh
they're they're they're they're they're
having fun
wearing costumes and singing dancing
around oh boy it's
it's scary stuff
listen this [ __ ] this is gross
listen to it I praised him for violent
Behavior really early there's something
that works and
you'll get immediate results
and you'll always a good fight had you
taught him more tolerance let me be
direct do you think uh you know it he
would have been more tolerant of gay
people apparently I think that my
anti-day
anti-smetics that comes from sort of a
writing of conservative extraordinaire
and I've been very vocal about that it
was I support Randy lapel her Grandpa I
love Brian Eagleville
there you have it his anti-gay
anti-Semitic
there it is
how Tony what does this guy have to do
with the meeting with Kanye everything
all of it
has everything to do with it
if you're still wondering why that
[ __ ] little fat [ __ ] went into Club Q
and murdered people because of who they
are well you're an idiot you're a dumb
[ __ ]
you're not paying attention
it's Maga
they're domestic terrorists just like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] here who encouraged
his son as a young age to use violence
as a way to solve his problems I talked
about this last week this is the gun
culture problem we have is if you got a
problem and you're a white guy a gun
will solve it
and then you have this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] over here Randy vopel
the kid's Grandpa who's apparently some
sitting politician in California
thinks the Insurrection was akin to the
Revolutionary War
I wonder if he holds anti-anti-gay and
anti-semitic use hmm
listen to what he says about him listen
to what he says about this Randy vopel
a good American Health bill for you
president someday
um
he says he's going to be president
someday
hmm
whoosh
whoosh
and here's fake Cape here's fakey that
dude has not even been a part of the
kid's life
hey Gabe you really
this is why I have you here
so I have you here that's why I keep you
here so I don't ban you on the Facebook
page
because you bear it all out for everyone
to see
you literally you literally are making
excuses
for the guy on the screen who is an
anti-semite
anti-gay
promoting violence saying thank God his
son wasn't gay because he was in the gay
bar I'm glad he was there to murder
people
and you're saying here's what you're
saying fake Gabe because I know you're
in the Trump copy machine you've you
[ __ ] read this somewhere you you
don't think for yourself you only type
out what they what they [ __ ] what
they you know force feed you to type out
here in the chat
let me tell you what you're saying what
everyone knows what you're saying
is that just because
this guy's saying this doesn't mean
that's exactly why the guy went and
killed those people
you're you are justifying the ACT dummy
you're justifying the ACT
of mass murdering people because they
dress up a certain way they are a
certain person and you are this guy
you're Randy vopel here the guy in the
[ __ ] terminal in Seattle Washington
that's you dude that's you I've been
trying to tell you for a while now I've
been trying to get it
you know pound it in your thick [ __ ]
skull fake game but that this is you
these are your peeps
these are your peeps man
that's who you're simping for
let's continue to see who fake Gabe is
something for Granny who all
righty that's a good man right there
that's a that's the best man for the job
because it was okay to be gay you know
nothing because it's a cool to be gay
it's not I think it's not cool at all I
think it's um my opinion about gays is
that you're just not okay because she's
standing against homosexuality I praise
him for violence
stand up as homosexuality how how would
he how would a guy like this vague how
do you think this would be how do you
think this would be
the way
that you would stand up to gaze you
think it would be the thing you just
said where it was um I don't know use
violence because you get instant
gratification hmm
just kill them you know just go in where
they are and just kill them
and by you typing anything anything
absolutely anything
you typing anything even this get owned
by facts you typing anything other than
this guy is a vile piece of [ __ ] his son
is a vile piece of [ __ ] Randy vopel is a
vile piece of [ __ ]
I absolutely condemn hatred towards
anyone
lgbtq gay
Jewish people black people
Hispanic people
women absolute any hatred towards a
marginalized group of people it is not
okay
especially when it leads to the mass
murder of those people for who they are
if you're not typing that in you're him
you're with them
you're on their side
that's who you are dude
now welcome back to Monday okay let's
see what else do we have here
[Music]
let's see what else do we have I had
some oh
hey I got some good speaking of [ __ ]
more videos of Nazis
God damn boy do I have the Surfs have
been posting a ton of Matt Walsh videos
creepy car videos where he's doing a
video in the car I don't know if this is
like how he used to do his show
how he used to talk about how he wanted
to have you know sex with minors so that
he could be married to him forever
you know are you this is how he
absolutely obsessed about children's
genitalia in his car it's kind of weird
I would imagine
you know he should be doing in like a
white panel van or something I'm just
saying if you're gonna be do it right
that'd be on brand Matt Walsh but here's
the thing the Surfs
have been finding these videos they're
very easy to find by the way because
Matt Walsh still has this [ __ ] posted on
his YouTube channel
I'm not getting you he's not ashamed of
this [ __ ] he's not ashamed that he's a
weirdo none of them are ashamed that
they're weirdos Jesus Christ
Kanye West brought Milo yiannopoulos and
Nick Fuentes to Mar-A-Lago
to talk to Donald Trump about the 2024
race
you think they're ashamed of anything
get the [ __ ] out of here all right let's
listen to Matt Walsh here
talk about some weird [ __ ] because Matt
Walsh is a weird [ __ ] Minds we
have really two categories there are
non-consensual sex which is bad and then
we have consensual sex which we think is
always good that's what we that's what
we've that's what the culture says
that's what we a lot of us have uh most
of us it seems like that's the idea that
we have it's like as long as they're
consenting adults who choose to do this
thing then it must be okay
but the reality is
that there's a lot of bad sex there's a
lot of immoral sex there's a lot of
disordered gross harmful sex that is
nonetheless consensual
why does he give a rat's [ __ ] ass why
do weirdos like this who I I maybe it's
he can't get [ __ ] laid I don't know
[ __ ] I don't know
I really don't give a [ __ ] around these
beating off or not now if he's doing it
to illegal stuff you know what I'm
saying maybe we should investigate and
get his laptop I don't know maybe this
new Congress should investigate Matt
Walsh's laptop I'm just saying
there's a lot of stuff on that laptop
I'm sure there's a lot of [ __ ] on Matt
Walsh's laptop
at this
at this uh this Congress would want to
investigate
here's what I want to say
is why in the [ __ ] he's he's sitting
here talking in his car weirdly into a
cell phone
about consensual non-consensual sex and
and Matt there is only
two types of sex
and he didn't he didn't like that
that there's consent to sex and
non-consent sex
like there's two types there
the reason why he doesn't like that
because he doesn't like
when two gay people consent to gay
adults consent to have sex with each
other
he doesn't like that consent
and he he loves the non-consensual right
we have a because he's talked about this
on his show
where if you have a teenage girl and you
get her pregnant then she's your wife
forever he likes that non-consensual
type sex so he's against consensual sex
in most sense
for non-consensual let's continue Matt
let's see what other weird [ __ ] you puke
up all of the cases that I mentioned
all the cases I mentioned
um they're all immoral bad gross harmful
but they're not all rape some of them
were
not all of them
ah boys he's getting in there he's
getting into rape justifying territory
isn't he oh you're telling me Matt Walsh
justifies rape surely not surely not oh
yeah and until we acknowledge that there
are other ways to have immoral sexual
relations with a person until we reclaim
sexual morality and sexual boundaries we
will be stuck trying to condemn all bad
sex on the grounds of consent which
expands the idea of consent so broadly
as to render it meaningless so that when
we really need it when there is actual
non-consensual sex happening it we we
don't have any meaningful way to
describe it because the word consent has
has become to is is is increasingly
means nothing
when he wants to have non-consensual sex
with a teenage girl to get her pregnant
so he can marry her and she can be
married to him for the rest of time
he wants he doesn't want there to be any
you know muddy water about that
non-consensual type sex
listen this guy sits around and thinks
about this stuff I keep telling you
people listen Nick Fuentes and a lot of
people don't want me to show this Matt
Walsh guy you need to watch this [ __ ]
these are the people who are forming the
narratives and the messaging of the
Republican Party
okay these are the people who are
forming the narratives
and the platforms for them to get
elected on this politicization
of consensual non-consensual rape sex
type [ __ ] they can't stop that why do
you think they bring it up and return I
know you guys were at Thanksgiving and I
know your Uncle Earl the weird one you
know that you know him and fake Gabe
trade post on Facebook right they're in
the same Facebook group the same
Ivermectin horse paced Q Anon Facebook
group
your Uncle Earl said something something
about drag shows or them transgenders
[Music]
or them gay sexies well they're having
that gay sex
he said something
said something I know I know he's got
the manga hat on
I know who he is I got a lot of them in
my family
all right let's continue with uh oh MC
rapey here because we've expanded it so
much and we've turned it into this
complicated equation where nobody really
knows when consent is happening and even
if a person does something willingly and
is like yes let's do this and but even
that might not be consent because we've
turned consent into this super confusing
uh calculus Minds oh this guy
now surfs had posted a shitload more of
this video and there's hours and hours
and hours of this game
just you can't stop talking weirdly in
his car
about sex he can't stop
he just keeps going
and going
and
going
and there's hours of it
um and you can go to his his uh
his YouTube channel you want best way is
just go to surfs and get that they post
a shitload of clips of this weirdo
talking about this type of stuff
right
but this is all aimed towards demonizing
groups of people
it's stochastic terrorism
again you say what does that have to do
with the meeting now Mar-A-Lago
everything
it has everything to do with it
I'm gonna watch some videos of Nick
Fuentes I promise you we're gonna get
there
I promise you we're going to watch a few
here of Nick Fuentes I mean there's a
million of him saying all kinds of gross
files [ __ ]
that [ __ ] Nazi when you're a Nazi you
say Nazi type [ __ ]
like and it's it's it's vile [ __ ] it's
incredible that you would sit in front
of a microphone and say that [ __ ]
but he does it
because he's a Nazi but don't get
confused Nazi comes in all different
forms these Nazis come in all different
forms here's another Nazi form formation
that has happened
I don't know what church this is
um and it's some kind of Baptist Church
of course they put the name Baptist
on any church
that they don't want to be affiliated
with some something or somewhere
yeah and I'm not sure what this guy's
name is he's the minister though at this
church he's the head Nazi Minister head
minister at this church
and he's talking here in this little
um
Sherman that he has oh my God
and people are wondering why Jin Z in
this entire country is sick and tired of
[ __ ] Christianity they're tired of it
it's because of [ __ ] like this
and they're not tired of it because they
don't believe or they don't have faith
right like that's such a [ __ ] myth
now there is a lot of people who are
atheists I'm an atheist Gabe is an
atheist there's a lot of people who are
atheists and the reason why we're able
to say we're atheists is because it's
not a big deal to not believe in this
day and age it's 20 22. like I don't
believe in Santa Claus either
I'm okay with it right most people are
like you know you don't believe
we're not in an age where atheists are
trying to get people to not believe
right the Christians are doing that good
enough themselves really honestly
the people who be who claim to run the
churches they're running people off from
their faith and getting them not to
believe in God better than [ __ ] an
atheist could ever do could ever do
to be quite honest it's like this guy
here and he claims to be a man of God
right now I mean you would think the
simple logic that if God made everything
or God was the creator and he created
humans and you know I never understood
this logic that you would hate another
human being
and if you really truly believe in God
right and you believe Jesus Christ is
the Messiah and the Savior right if you
believe that stuff now you might have a
different religion but let's say you
believe it for a second wouldn't you
believe
may God
that God created all men all women all
genders all Races all religions wouldn't
you believe that
I don't know
I think you would I mean you should
maybe
but then Christ Jesus Christ dies on the
cross
for all your sins which means all other
people's sins that God created too so
you would think you would believe that
right at least at a bare [ __ ] minimum
you would believe the simple [ __ ]
things that you say you believe
just the simple ones you know you don't
have to get into many Bible verses or
you know
uh theory about the Bible or about your
religion just the simple the simple
[ __ ] principle
there's a God created Everything Jesus
died on the cross for everyone's sins
right
pretty simple [ __ ]
but let's listen to the sermon
on this Nazi that uh Club got shut up
the other day now am I sad
that five homos got shot no I'm not sad
at all as a matter of fact I think it's
a good thing
that they're not here anymore to molest
kids and I'm again I'm not condoning
anybody to do anything like that I don't
believe it's right to take the law into
our own hands and I've said that so many
times but here's what I won't be upset
about I'm not going to be upset when
someone that hates God inactively is
promoting against God and hates his guts
and molest children even if it is just
their eyeballs
to have to see these freaks riding
around and and and you know doing all
these crazy dances in front of children
and then afterwards reading them a book
or something I said it's not right to
take the law into your own hands but I
do understand why people are so fed up
because our own government is protecting
these Freaks and that's all you see on
the media right now you know right wing
Mega kills you know these these queers
and then some guy jumped in and helped
him or whatever who cares
like I really don't care that those
people got killed you're like that
sounds really hateful Pastor well it is
hateful
because I do hate them because they're a
menace and a wart on the rear end of
society
and amen he says oh my god oh
hey fake Gabe this is you
you don't know it you definitely don't
know it you're all hopped up on Q Anon
Facebook Q Anon
to boot this guy this guy is you
foreign
type in to the chat
everything you type in this guy supports
every narrative that you try to come in
and say oh you're lying Tony look at you
you yeah I owned you with the facts
this guy would do the same [ __ ]
every time
this is your dude
this is your guy he's you you were him
same [ __ ]
same [ __ ] see look see you're
already see I'm not even gonna put that
[ __ ] up on the screen
and then you're gonna put the [ __ ] up on
the screen but you are this guy
this is you
so and you're not even grossed out by
him like you're not even grossed out by
this [ __ ] but let me tell you
something folks the reason why I'm
always on fake Gabe and and I'm not
trying to cause trouble with him I
actually like to have him here because
he's reliable he's here every day I know
exactly what he's going to type in
before he types it in it's easy to say
it's easy to see just like it's easy to
see that this [ __ ] this [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] right here who claims to be a
[ __ ] minister of God and the word of
God listen I know Christians I actually
know some actual Christians not this
[ __ ] [ __ ] trumped up [ __ ]
white nationalism
these [ __ ] Nazis
this isn't Christianity this isn't
religion when you're telling when when
you're saying I I yeah I [ __ ] hate
him kill him kill him kill him kill him
it's not it's not any kind of religion
it's definitely not Christianity for
sure
why do you think everyone's driving away
from the church because the [ __ ]
piece is a [ __ ] like this
he says he hates him now I I know
I know it seems trivial here
but the ending on this
is the reason why I wanted to show you
this this is the ending on this is the
reason why I want to show you watch
there there's nothing redeeming about
them whatsoever
yeah well listen we're in America
we can say whatever we want
and I'm not inciting violence so don't
even try to go there
but anyway Happy Happy Thanksgiving
did you catch the ending there I'm not
[ __ ] you that's the most important
part about the whole thing I know it
feels like oh well he's hatred and [ __ ]
nope I'm telling you this right here
this ending
is the most important thing about it and
let me let me play it here we go watch
this ending again listen we're in
America
we can say whatever we want
and I'm not inciting violence so don't
even try to go there
but anyway Happy Happy Thanksgiving
Happy Thanksgiving now that's not the
part I'm talking about obviously it's
it's a little [ __ ] weird that he
would end his little diagram with well
Happy Thanksgiving hell go go eat turkey
Oh yay Jesus Jesus and turkey
all right
I'm talking about the part where he
thinks it's his white privilege to say
and incite any kind of violence he wants
and drive crazy people to go kill gays
because he hates them that's his right
it's his white privilege he's a white
man he's a white man
he gets to say whatever he wants
as a white man as a white Christian man
he gets to say whatever he wants and he
has to pay no price whatsoever
it's the same [ __ ] it's the reason why
Kanye took [ __ ] Mario unopoulos
and Nick Fuentes to go see the king of
the white dudes
it's same [ __ ] it's the same reason why
Elon is now [ __ ] making Twitter an
absolute [ __ ] Nazi Haven
I'm white I get to say what I want and
not only that I'm a white male God damn
it
you can't stop me you can't give me
consequences my speech my my
words don't have consequences
because I'm a white man that's what he's
saying
you I'll [ __ ] Play It Again watch
I'll [ __ ] Play It Again
there it is here it is listen
we're in America
we could say whatever we want
and I'm not inciting violence so don't
even try to go there
but anyway Happy Happy Thanksgiving he
means white dudes he means white dudes
get to say whatever they want without
consequence
that's what he's saying
uh Dave uh
50 Shades away posted that on Twitter it
said and he says here let me show you
the tweet
apparently it was in Colorado I'm not
sure what this guy's name is I'm sure
it's in the thread and I'm sure there's
plenty of other vile [ __ ] video now
again this is the other thing too this
guy is setting up a camera setting up a
microphone to say this [ __ ] to record it
it ain't like someone caught him off
guard it ain't like someone is sitting
in the Pew going whoa what the [ __ ]
this guy saying they turn on their cell
phone and they record him no this
[ __ ] is producing this video to
disseminate it to his followers his
other trumped up white dude followers
you can guarantee that yeah 50 Shades
away says a pastor celebrated a mass
shooting in Colorado saying it was a
good oh the bashing in Colorado I don't
know where this is at I have no idea
um
friendlyavius.com apparently posted it
um this is exactly why hate Grimes are
happening against oppressed people Dave
says
exactly
it's this type of [ __ ] it's the reason
it's the reason why the significance
of Nazis dining with the king of the
trumped up white dudes is so [ __ ]
important
and it's so important for us to say it
the way that it needs to be said not oh
well he's a uh on a Kanye West went and
visited his friend Donald Trump and they
were gonna eat dinner and it just so
happened it just so happened that a
holocaust denier was in Kanye's pocket
when he walked in Mar-A-Lago Trump not
known the difference no they're [ __ ]
Nazis I don't care I don't care if
you're like you're calling Kanye West a
Nazi you goddamn right I am you [ __ ]
ain't right I am yes Kanye West Kanye
West is a Nazi
I said it a thousand times
if if there's a Nazi sitting at a
[ __ ] table
and there's 10 other people sitting
there dining and eating with the Nazi
you got 11 Nazis at the table
11 of them not one you got eleven
that's how this [ __ ] works
okay
um
oh fake game I'm spewing nonsensical
[ __ ] well then you're here every day
man
you're here every [ __ ] day
every [ __ ] day
every day man
whoosh
him and Jeremy Johnson
oh Jeremy's at easy easy easily more
racist than than fake game if you can
imagine I want to show you a video here
of um Carrie late Nazis now this is
maybe a different little different breed
in Nazi
but these are Carrie late I know it's
hard to see them because there's not
that many
um this is over the weekend at the
Arizona State Capitol apparently even
the head Nazi Donald Trump himself
um has
said that he wants Carrie Lake installed
as the governor remember when I said
weeks before the election that they were
that one they wanted the most the
election they wanted the most was
Arizona that's the one they wanted they
wanted Kerry Lake they wanted Blake
Masters and they wanted mark fincham
that's who they wanted they wanted those
three man they wanted those races bad
because if they could get those those
races won they could prove that election
denialism is a way to run a state
and Carey Lake would do everything in
her power to try to make sure that we
went over the 2020 election every single
week like every week you'd be like oh
we're gonna recount and we're gonna do
another audience we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna decertify all this [ __ ]
just nonsense
absolute [ __ ] garbage it doesn't
exist and there's nothing in our Federal
Constitution or the State Constitution
that allows them to do anything that
they wanted to do none of it
but now Trump the king Nazi wants to
install
he said that he said the words not me uh
install Kerry Lake
to the governorship of Arizona now these
people here in this video they're out to
support this idea that they're going to
overturn the election
in the state of Arizona
watch the crowd of people
that isn't there
this morning
[Music]
but I can't
I can't watch the channel
when I'm doing interviews too hard
so these are live streamers who are live
streaming the
you know 12 people that are there I
don't know let's see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten ah there
might be there might be tens of people
there might be tens of people that went
to lay Siege on the Arizona capitol
right this is [ __ ] pathetic now you
would say Tony come on this was early on
this was in the very beginning
there's no way that this is
this is the only no that's it that's all
that showed up that's it and they have
these things all weekend
it's not even really worth showing
really I mean I guess I could try to
find a video here but it's not anymore
showing
pathetic it's pathetic
and they're pathetic
okay uh let's go to speaking of that
Donald Trump
let me see if I can find that statement
that I sh the the
Kerry Lake one
I want to show you that one and I want
to show you a few others uh Spiro that
goes to Spiro Agnew had um
was posting a lot of these they they
Spiro's ghost here's the account here
post a lot of Trump's post over on
true social I posted them too now the
ones that are significant that I'd be
like
are newsworthy in other words
now um I wasn't on social media a lot
this weekend I tried to take a break you
know I I when I was lurking but I wasn't
really
tweeting much and I really didn't pay
too much of attention other than the
things I really needed to pay attention
to one of them was Grandpa boopy band's
freakouts
um about Jack Smith
but here is the one
about Carrie Lake uh massive numbers
this is Grandpa this is Grandpa
Poopypants this is the the Cheeto dust q
and honor the head Nazi
massive numbers are broken in quotes and
capitalize I don't understand
is he trying to make sure we see the
word broken
I mean he puts it in quotes properly
here like oh they were broken but they
weren't broken type thing you know
that's what he's trying to say that they
weren't actually broken
but he does the capital thing too voting
machines in Republican districts on
Election Day
whoosh uh
mechanic sent in to fix them
made them worse
lies Carrie had to be taken to a
Democrat area taken what does that mean
did they hold her in a bunker well I
don't understand this and a Democrat
area I don't know is he saying I I'm not
even gonna go there uh which was working
perfectly to vote by the way those
Democrat machines
because we know we know we know
that there's Democrat machines and
Republican machines have you been to the
voting booth
you're not allowed if you're a Democrat
you're not allowed to stick a pallet in
a republican machine the Republican is
not allowed to take one of the Democrat
haven't you ever been there you've been
there oh my God this these [ __ ]
people
outside their minds
here's what he says he says her opponent
ran the election
Katie Hobbs is the elected Secretary of
State
and in states where the secretary of
state is elected
they do generally run the election their
office runs the election
that's how it works in every state even
like in Georgia when Kemp was the
Secretary of State and he ran that
election
goes on to say [ __ ] goes on to say this
is yet another criminal voting operation
so obvious
capital letters there Kerry Lake here's
the statement I told you he'd [ __ ]
typed this out
Kerry Lake should be installed governor
of Arizona now
everyone's speculating this morning why
and all the blah blah blah he wanted
this race bad I explained why he wanted
this race the worst and the reason why
is because she was going to be most
adamant about
crowning him king of 2020.
as the governor of Arizona
but where why he's saying here Carey
Lake should be installed governor of
Arizona he doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about Gary Lake you don't really give a
[ __ ] about her election he didn't give a
[ __ ]
he only cares about the imagery of
installing someone who didn't win that's
important because he goes on to say here
this is almost as bad as 2020
presidential elections he's projecting
he's projecting every single [ __ ]
time this guy is projecting which the
unselect committee refuses to touch
because they know it was fraudulent
dude they've hashed out the 2020
election when you've tried to steal it
you dumb [ __ ]
they're actually figuring out the fake
collector scheme
there's probably going to be indictments
including yours with Jack Smith that's
why you're so [ __ ] terrified of that
guy which I mean I would be scared of
Jack Smith too don't don't don't get me
wrong I would be terrified if a guy who
prosecutes war criminals was Prosecuting
me that would kind of make me [ __ ] my
britches
but what he's saying here when he says
Carrie Lake should be installed governor
of Arizona he's saying I should be
installed president of the United States
so I can pardon myself so Jack Smith
can't touch me that's what he's saying
that's I'll I'll give you the
translation if you need it but
he's [ __ ] he's [ __ ] crazy and
here's what Spiro's gonna said about
this uh particular post
um
says the trademark of a very stable
Jesus is to unleash a completely
deranged live-filled unhinged misleading
rant at 2 30 a.m this guy posted this
dude posted this at 2 30 A.M this is the
[ __ ] he's thinking about this is a [ __ ]
he's sweating when he wakes up
and he's got to change his diaper in the
middle of the night you know you got
that that midnight diaper change right I
don't know I don't wear diapers so I'm
assuming
that you'd have to get up in the middle
night and change your shitty diaper
because he's been dreaming that Jack
Smith's gonna bury his ass put him in
that [ __ ] federal prison somewhere so
you wake up at 2 30 change your diaper
and you're you know you're a little
upset you're pissed off so you go on a
you know rant and Rave about to carry
Lake and how you'd like to install her
is the king of Arizona just like you
want to be installed King of the United
States you can pardon yourself fire Jack
Smith who who's a prosecutor of war
criminals and he's he's about to crawl
up in your ass and live there for about
a year and a half
so he also goes on to Spiro's ghost goes
on to say he is so rattled by Carrie
Lake losing that he has no idea what to
expect to ex to expect to say she should
be installed as governor of Arizona very
normal sane stuff again I I don't think
this has to do with
I mean he's a lunatic but this has to do
with he's desperate to become the king
even to normalize
crowning someone else King okay so let's
get to because I can read a thousand
[ __ ]
now you can read a thousand of these
statements right
um let's see maybe just one from Jack
Smith I don't know should we give one ah
[ __ ] it I'm not even gonna he's
terrified of Jack Smith you just go look
at true social or go to Spiros
Twitter page and read
the post he was putting on fraud social
over the weekend about
Jack Smith
whoosh dude is terrified okay let's go
to some uh Nick Fuentes videos I
definitely want to see these
um let's see I think
I believe I believe Ron had a bunch of
these videos post over the weekend but
let's let's see what we get here
do you remember
um
when Marjorie Taylor green went and
spoke at the America First Nazi rally do
you remember that
yeah and I talked about it on the show
[ __ ] you go back look at the date go
pull the show you can pull the clip and
and you talk about AB you know
this was but here's the thing the media
is getting this all [ __ ] wrong
like they're just they're just getting
us wrong here is a description of this
on CNN let's listen he hasn't denounced
Fuentes views in those statements and if
you're not familiar Fuentes has this
high profile figure on the far right a
holocaust denier but he's best known for
running the America First organization
which according to the ADL quote seeks
to forge a white nationalist alternative
to the mainstream GOP
foreign we've got the white Christian
men that built this country the first
time and we'll do it again
okay now and let me pull the banner down
here because I want to show you this I
told you this is what they were doing
look um down here at the bottom let me
rewind it just a bit here so I can show
you okay so they got Nick Fuentes here
white nationalist I told you that's what
they're calling him and Holocaust denier
white nationalist and Holocaust he's a
Nazi he's a [ __ ] Nazi let's continue
CNN with your [ __ ] up you're [ __ ]
this up
Fuentes attended the deadly white
supremacist rally in Charlottesville
Virginia in 2017. it was it was a Nazi
rally they were Nazis
they were Nazis I also recently called
for the military to be sent into black
neighborhoods
just send the military engine do what
must be done send the military into
these black neighborhoods make the
streets safe they'll complain about it
it doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter they're never going to vote for
us
CNN has told Trump found Fuentes very
interesting during their dinner and fun
says praised Trump when he ad-libs his
speeches that led the former president
to tell other people at the table quote
he gets me
so he gets him but they can't get it
right when they put on the screen that
Nick Fuentes is in white nationalist
and a holocaust he's a Nazi
God damn it
okay let's um see if I can find some
oh yeah here here's here's where he's
introducing
um Marjorie Taylor green at the America
First Nazi party rally
I've been calling I I
me the Tony Michaels has been calling
Nick Fuentes and the Republican party
you know this you know this
for months the America First Nazi party
I say it out loud the America First Nazi
party
there's a reason why I've been saying it
I'm just say this [ __ ] just say it
there's a reason
we must build a national narrative yes
it's rhetoric yeah fake Gabe it is
rhetoric oh yeah good job I'm abundant I
I spew rhetoric into a microphone thing
Gabe we must build a national narrative
that forces Republicans to choose
are you going to choose
trumpism Nazism the Nick Fuentes part of
the party the America First Nazi party
are you going to get back talking about
deficits
and budgets
and taxes
what you gonna do you're gonna listen to
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh Matt Getz
Marjorie Taylor green
and Ron DeSantis
denigrate marginalized communities like
transgender and lgbtq Community you're
going to do that
or are you going to get back to [ __ ]
arguing about tax policy which is it
you we can make them decide with our
national narrative
and we do that with rhetoric we do that
with politics baby that's how this works
that's what this microphone is for
that's what my voice is for
here is uh here's the little Nazi Nick
Fuentes introducing another Nazi Margie
Taylor green listen to who he listen to
who he wants everyone to cheer for and
you wonder why Marjorie Taylor green is
up so far up Putin's ass let's listen
and now they're going on about Russia
and Vladimir Putin is Hitler and they
say that's not a good thing and
can we give a ride of Applause for
Russia
everyone says oh he's a holocaust and
iron he's not he's not a Nazi he's just
a white nationalist he's just it's
America First dude is standing up saying
he wants Putin to be Hitler and then
he's like let's give Applause
for Russia's Hitler
okay
and who he's about to introduce Marjorie
Taylor green there's no [ __ ] bigger
Putin's puppet than this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's right I said it Marjorie Taylor
green is a Nazi [ __ ]
[Applause]
absolutely absolutely we are honored we
are humbled and excited to Welcome to
the stage right now for our first speech
and we'd love to get to know her much
better I think this is going to be the
beginning of something great the
representative from Georgia Marjorie
Taylor Greene
can you can you feel the Nazi energy in
the room oh my God
give me a break
again
this is months ago that this happened
this didn't happen [ __ ] yesterday we
talked about it on the show
how we should make every single
Republican
pay
for that [ __ ] for that moment
uh let's see here's um here's another
video that right wing watch right wing
watch is all over Nick Fuentes too
I'm pointing him out I actually I I
think there was one point
and that check with Gabe Sanchez and I
don't know if he's listening uh or if
he's in the chat but uh um he's not he's
not on the show today because he kind of
lost his voice
because of the sickness
here's the thing
I believe at one point Nick Fuentes
mentioned our show on his show I don't
know I can never I could never really
find it
nice right wing watch to see if they
knew how to find it but there's no real
archive that you can just search
and this guy spews Nazi [ __ ] into a
microphone
constantly so it's hard to find son I
don't know if he actually did or not but
right wing watch is all over Nick
Fuentes now keeping track of him making
sure we know
exactly what the [ __ ] he's spewing up
and it's my job to show you
my job to show you and to break it down
but here's here's a another [ __ ]
video of this vile piece of [ __ ] I think
he's talking about women how much he
hates women in this one can you imagine
a Nazi hating women once listen we're
allowing women to go out into the
society and
Ai and bear false witness and cast
spells and worship minerals and rocks
and women are out there naked and
they're killing babies and they're
getting to be 300 pounds and they get in
your face and we can't do anything about
it you can't hit these people you can't
punch them you can't they don't arrest
them and basically they're taking over
the culture on social media I said what
happened to the good old days a thousand
years ago when people like this instead
of arguing with them or saying Hey
listen darling everything's okay they
would dunk them in the river burn them
alive I said this is this is the kind of
thing that we need to see more of is
burning them alive a little a little bit
more
taking women like this and instead of uh
you know hiring a lawyer for all this
money and we're going to sue him for
defamation
how about we we go to the Constable or
whatever we go to the uh the police
officer the soldier station in the
village and say hey um
we got to burn her alive
you know hey this woman is worshiping
rocks she's bearing false witness she's
she's lying about men
and basically we need to capture her and
and uh throw her in the lake
or set her on fire I feel like that
would be more appropriate and everybody
freaked out and this was all over
Twitter and everybody said oh this is
horrible is this guy for Real uh yeah
I'm for real
there you have it words out of his own
mouth
I don't know what else you could say I
don't know how else you could frame this
up
I don't know I mean we can play a
thousand clips that are just as bad or
worse than the one I just played and we
will play more of them I am sure
this is who Trump dined with
this is who Trump supporters are
cheering that Trump dined with
you got that they're not [ __ ] ashamed
of it they're not ashamed that Trump
dying with this person this is how they
think why would they be ashamed of it
why would these
sick little white trumped up male in
cells be offended that this guy was
saying this why why would they be
offended they're not offended it's what
they believe it's what they feel deep
down inside their little weak [ __ ]
incel bodies
they're so insecure they're so
insignificant that anyone anyone with a
bit of confidence especially a woman
especially a heavy woman a beautiful
confident heavy woman oh baby you talk
about you talk about really triggering a
[ __ ] white male in cell whoosh
that'll set them off
but this is who he was dining with this
is who they want support from Kanye West
even said on I don't know some [ __ ]
weird ass podcast that the most the most
oppressed person in this country is a
white man Kanye West said that [ __ ] and
then he's hiring Milo yunopolis
as his [ __ ] campaign manager victim
number one Milo yiannopoulos who worked
for Marjorie Taylor green who
Nick Fuentes said himself you just saw
it in a clip saying we can't wait to
build this relationship
folks this is not happenstance this was
not an accident
that these [ __ ] ended up down at
Mar-A-Lago eating Big Macs with Trump
it was all part of the plan Trump wanted
a piece of the Nazi action
he wanted some of it
he wanted Fuentes to be there he wanted
Milo to be there he wanted Kanye to come
down and kiss his ring
to let them know that he is the king
Nazi
that's what they wanted
and that's what it is
it was a meeting and a dinner with Nazis
Trump dined with Nazis and again I know
we're at the end of the show and I know
I've said this several times today and
we're gonna keep saying it we're not
gonna stop
if there is a Nazi
at a table
and there are 10 people
eating dining
with that Nazi there are 11 Nazis at
that table
11 of them
that is all it takes
everyone welcome back this week I hope
you had a great holiday weekend I hope
it was safe I hope you're full I hope
your belly's full I hope you're you're
regretting the scale this morning I
really am because my food was great The
Leftovers were great I hope you had a
great holiday weekend
everybody welcome back tomorrow we is
Tuesday we will have Texas Paul
hopefully Gabe Sanchez's voice is much
better tomorrow or we can have our
co-host Gabe Sanchez on because every
single Tuesday is Taco Tuesday in Texas
Paul Tuesday here at the Tony Michaels
podcast everyone you're the greatest
audience in the world show us some
support however you can retweet us like
us share the show email the YouTube link
share it on your social media sites you
can go to tonymichaels.live you can give
a tip there if you want to give a
one-time tip or set it up monthly you
can also go to store.thetonymichaels.com
and grab some winter gear Christmas is
coming up these make great gifts I
promise you we got coffee mugs sweaters
hoodies t-shirts the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty is the hot item on
store.thetonymichaels.com right here use
the promo code podcast use the promo
code podcast get 10 off your entire
purchase
show support for the show we really
appreciate you guys I appreciate you
hanging out with me today
the first day back from our vacation
we will see you tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon